oh my god my two least favorite things
truly I hate bananas as well did I say
that I probably said I particularly
hated raw tomatoes
I find them graphic hilarious appreciate
you having us oh yeah can you carry
Tomatoes or sometimes if they're sliced
like the thing and try to talk into the
mic as we're in a pretty spacious room
here very nice
so yeah the banana it wasn't the
connotation there was a comedy of the
scene that was really yeah I watched it
yesterday I watched the movie yesterday
and just the emotional connection to
scenes that I felt like the well one in
the I don't I won't get too detailed
into the yeah just the spoiling but like
the car scene I felt like claustrophobic
yeah yeah in my seat just like oh gosh
like washing through my fingers and then
the the pool scene was another one yeah
yeah where it was almost like she was
going to you're going to slay a dragon
yeah what it felt like how do you how do
you inject such like a vivid emotion
into a scene like that
I think it's just well for those it
really is just giving the scenes time
and not cutting away and not not cutting
out this sort of boring white noise
that's sort of happening between the
moments because I think it is when you
experience moments in real time with
people but that's where discomfort and
anxiety comes from so yeah I mean like
the pool party it's like we follow her
from the top of this to you know pretty
much in real time all the way she gets
to the pool and part of it was just that
wanting to feel like you're really in
this with her it was actually like some
of the film was inspired by like VR like
doing PR like I got like a little psvr
you know the PlayStation like version VR
in doing that doing some of the VR I was
like man this is what I want the movie
to feel like actually like I actually
like if I could do a version of the
movie because people are like oh would
you want to make this into a book or a
television show like no if I wanted to
make this than anything else would be a
VR experience like to walk through the
pool party as good yeah yeah just like
and then technically sort of the way you
do that is just really wide lenses and
get close to her so you allow the
audience to like you're not telling them
what to look at necessarily you know
they have a bacon kind of they have
their own field of vision and and so I
almost gives them the emotional range to
pick how they feel about it
exactly you telling them how they're
feeling that's the hope to is just like
again like cuts coverage cutting into
things cutting away from things is
actually given the audience and out you
know and if you can actually force them
to stay in this moment that's where it
becomes I'm saying cuz you know the main
character Kayla she would love to be
able to cut away from the pool scene you
know she would love to be able to
experience these moments as montages but
she has to sit through them in real time
and that's sort of yeah was the idea for
the film as well and what's the perfect
timing of this film is one you film this
right after leaving eighth grade yeah
which is super it's the perfect timing
it's it really is like an amazing
performance you put on thank you in in
time at the emotion of the scene how
much of it how much do you have to like
it's
because in researching you guys it's
just funny to hear beau say I wrote this
as I feel now as opposed to when I was
in eighth grade and then it's it's an
eighth if eighth grade girl who is
resonating with this story that like a
27 year old man wrote it like how was it
kind of fusing those two worlds together
even in reading the script like
immediately I mean yeah I think a lot of
it came to life and I felt it more when
we actually started filming because
reading the script I obviously felt a
connection but like reading it for the
first time it wasn't as strong as when
we were doing it and I mean I don't know
I don't think the times are too
different is that like yeah he's an
older man and I'm liking you know a
freshman girl but like the feelings are
still the same we're just people you
know mm-hmm
yeah I am I don't know I felt like I
just understood her pretty basically and
it was just a belief that like like like
she said the feelings are the same like
panic fear it's the same thing anymore
you know for me it was backstage at a
theater instead of in the bathroom
before a pool party you only mean but
the feeling was the same so and I was
actually looking forward to exploring
these feelings outside of the context of
my own life because all I was doing was
exploring them in terms of my literal
life so yeah if the question was what
the the problem is just pretty natural
I mean it just so organically the movie
had that feel - I mean my mind
immediately went to even just hearing
the score and just the the the kind of
the feel of the movie were just like
John Hughes I was just feeling this is a
modern day John Hughes movie and this is
a filmmaker who has found a direction
who's really gonna like really feel like
you found a new voice really oh that's
really nice yeah well you know the John
Hughes thing is like I'm hearing stories
of people saying like when he made the
Breakfast Club or something people would
go like why are you taking this so
seriously you're acting
like being in high schools like being in
Vietnam it's not that big of a deal you
know so I hope that's that's the
connection I really feel to him you know
in in terms of because I mean he is
about another time so I don't really
totally resonate with the kids in this
movie just because they weren't totally
from my time of growing out but but what
I what I do really what resonated with
me about his movie is now hope this
movie does the same thing is that it
takes kids seriously on their own terms
yet you know it's in says that you know
Breakfast Club or sixteen Candles it
says this is important to them now and
that's all that matters and we're not
totally looking at it from the
perspective of adults who've lived
through this and are now looking back
and saying oh okay well in in light of
all of life's circumstances this is
actually not that significant or they're
actually the only important thing about
being in school it's like what interests
you cultivate that will eventually
become your career like we are we who
cares like we were making this film we
felt like America was gonna blow up any
day truly like so it was like we don't
even know if you're gonna have an
adulthood so it's really just like can
can we make it and what the movie should
feel like it's like does she make it to
the end of this week okay feeling okay
being okay it doesn't matter what the
adult she becomes you know like that
battle that's all that she has plenty of
time to sort that out so that was the so
that's the job that's what I hope the
connection is with John Hughes that we
we take kids seriously on their own
terms and not don't adult a5a thing
especially now more than ever with kids
are pretty much grownups and it forced
me to be nostalgic and thinking man when
I was in eighth grade I had dial-up yeah
named Pokemon car yeah yeah and it was
just like yeah but it's the same world
so even to get a view through your world
and seeing like resonating with that
even just from a different dimension
almost but still seeing the through line
yeah it really forced me to like step
back the I mean the in the closing shot
I like I started to like cry I was just
like oh my gosh it just took now this
entire roller coaster so kudos to the
riding and kudos
LL Bean backpack is very special yeah
you see I made her like there's some
things that would be taken from my life
for her like little LL Bean backpack
with her initials in great like yeah
that's so I mean that's everyone I grew
up with us we all have those like corny
lopa backpack and I think the backpacks
may have gotten a little cooler in the
meantime I feel like kids have like cool
likes normally yeah yeah yeah yeah no
totally they look like kind of like her
or something you know it's all very yeah
but uh but you can tell even just in
your comedy alone just the attention to
detail I think it's something people
like oh man he's doing all these
innovative things but it's like it's in
the details and the same thing shows in
this movie in the details like the book
bag or the pool scene which is about to
come out and then there's like a comedic
moment yeah yeah right now those little
details are really I think what makes
the difference between something that
resonates is something that just kind of
Peters off so in even working together I
know you're very detail-oriented in your
stand-up and I've heard you say you
spent 30 hours on like a five-minute
piece um with so in the movie what and
this may be directed at you in just the
sense of in his direction and detail
orientation like how many takes would
you do whether what was the kind of
relationship behind the scenes yeah
in the sense of like takes and stuff I
guess it's very dependent on the scenes
like with the dinner scene between me
and Josh that one we did a lot to get
that relationship right you know so I
like we use like the last take for that
right something like that so I was
actually annoyed by the end she wanted
that see how many takes like how long
are we talking here 30 yeah 30 was the
whole day though a lot of the day yeah
was that scene yeah yeah um yeah I don't
know I think a lot of cool stuff the
question did I feel yeah yeah baring it
no no no no no but really did I feel no
as he's directing you now he's saving me
from my anxiousness um would you share
of course oh yeah yeah of course
y'know not overbearing dudes I feel
detail Orion no I mean I wouldn't say
particularly because a lot of this is
kind of about like feeling your way
through stuff there obviously are like
you know little details I guess I don't
know yeah a lot of it was very like out
there open I guess I think I am that's
good what maybe I let her to that answer
I hope that's my I mean I was no but
they're all very detail-oriented but I
didn't want her or the actors of course
to feel any of that like they shouldn't
they shouldn't feel micromanage moment
oh yeah yeah like you know the whole
point is the way I'm detail-oriented of
course like with production and all that
stuff we have months and months and
months to prepare but as far as the the
film and the performances are
detail-oriented my job as a director on
set is to encourage an environment where
details can flourish freely and then
take inventory of those details as I'm
watching them take after take ever take
woohoo there oh there's a great moment
there who that little things happening
there but not to go okay like on this
may my favorite moments in the movie
details little thing as little
performances ticks on her face or little
moments of Josh and ARBs inherently
spontaneous they have to be in order to
be interesting so yeah my job is really
just to create an environment where
those things can yeah pop up and then my
detail-oriented job is really pre
production post-production but
production itself is like you're just
trying to make the soil rich and water
things and be encouraging more than you
are
yeah cuz yeah and editing you would
you'd be like 12 hours a day right just
like counting out yeah three four months
yeah yeah and then take a break to
direct a small special of just some
community and Chris Rock no big deal
there I've always say Chris Rock and LC
are very similar so it's just this I
just applied the same thing for LCD
Chris I'd love to hear LCD you are you
are similar how so Creek Chris's Chris's
um very thoughtful is a very thoughtful
person and very conscious of himself and
yeah I just think you both are interior
people hmm and I did include myself on
that
yeah and I'm saying I mean raucous I
mean he is of course very extrovert and
boisterous on stage but he's actually
and personally I think you know a very
interior contemplatively anxiety piece
and I'd be interested because so many
people even in my life like struggle
from anxiety what are some personal like
behaviors or personal even rituals what
have you guys been able to kind of
instill in your life to help with that I
mean okay uh I still don't have it under
control or handled or anything I started
to keeping a journal though that's
helped me kind of keep keep myself
grounded and if I ever feel myself like
panicking in my room or something I
start to read it and I'm like life is
happening I don't know if I'm if I'm
filming like if you feel like an attack
or something coming on I just close my
eyes and then it's weird but I pretend
like there's a feather there and my
breathing has to keep the feather like
floating in place yeah I do the same
thing with a bowling ball I just try to
keep the volleyball so no I drink water
and workout uh-huh that definitely helps
like exercise definitely helps if it's
bad you should go to therapy I should go
to therapy I'm not but I should or
anyone should go to therapy I don't but
I should and you ever
I've never went which is bad I know and
I should because I'm like the perfect
case for that should go to therapy but I
haven't but yeah I just meditate and
talk about it I mean that was the thing
that literally saved me was going like
I'm just gonna name it I'm just gonna
start talking about it I I didn't talk
about it for so long I didn't admit it
and that was sort of the thing happened
on stage I was like I'm really nervous
to go on stage all right I'm gonna make
my whole show about how nervous he wants
to it and then it kind of ate itself and
I was like well this isn't really
helping but and then I tried it here
yeah just get your manager to hit you in
the back as hard yeah exactly it I go
yes yeah just yeah
there's a it just put it out in the open
it I think that's the most dangerous
thing about anxiety is that it if it
becomes your personal secret you know
and that's what we hope in part the
movie can do the movie can kind of get
this thing out in the open and say this
is the experience everyone has or not
everyone has a lot of people have and
and or I think everyone has to varying
degrees but um it it's common and it's
exacerbated by the internet and it's I
think it's just only getting more calm
in this feeling I think there's gonna I
think her generation is gonna be a very
anxious generation I'm sure for sure I
mean I'm already seeing it and a lot of
kids I know like it's it's not you know
well I don't want to say special because
it never is but like it's not uncommon
to find anxiety and like everyone like
everyone is and I think social media
plays a part in that honestly because
everyone is just so worried about
everything all the time and then yeah
and it's it's been directly linked to
depression so it's definitely not going
anywhere so what is your goal with the
movie are you trying to bring an
awareness I mean it's almost like no no
we're not TED talk or PSA or anything I
mean really we're just trying to make a
good movie which is instead it just like
yeah well thank you just trying to
engage people in a thing make a
watchable interesting thing mm more than
it is like some public service it more
just like express a true feeling we have
yeah and and hopefully people can see it
and either empathize whether they're
sympathize with it or hate it it doesn't
really matter you know that was just the
goal make a good movie you know you have
ideas and themes on your head but then
when you get down to actually making the
movie it's like just tell the story
about this person yeah but even finding
that story took a lot of exploration and
refinement and you mentioned before in
interviews like having tent poles along
the way that you then built the movie
upon what were those tent poles yeah
like it was more just diving into scenes
and trying to write a movie that I just
wanted to
see what's a scene I would like what's
this another scene I would like and just
try to build an entire movie out of only
scenes I'd want to see and then when I
got you know 50 60 pages into it started
to realize okay now how do these things
maybe fit together but yeah I was
wanting to yeah there were no just like
throw a kid into fun stuff and build
from there and it was also in writing
just try to write something that I enjoy
writing the entire time you make it
sound so easy
well it's not none of this is good I
mean none of it all this could lead to
something not good this story in
particular sort of poured out very very
quickly in a couple weeks or so the
first draft at least but yeah when
writing is going well it feels yeah like
you know it can just be ten pages very
very quickly right um but and it feels
like listening when it's going really
well but that's only the first step and
then there's you know slamming your head
things going totally south and
questioning everything just in the
writing process alone not totaling the
writing process once the writing process
becomes once the writing itself is
viewed in light of production and as a
reality and I mean it's not just a fun
little script you have announced I think
it's actually gonna be made it needs to
be feasibly made and then you know it
aligns with the culture and then you're
looking at the cultural moment which is
obviously pretty high right now and
going wait wait is this gonna be
interpreted this way is this gonna be
seen that way you know I'm a man making
everybody on girls is there you know
like there's like there's a lot of stuff
to worry about understandably and
probably correctly so yeah you know if
there's a whole different thing between
a nice little idea of a thing that
you've finished on the paper for
yourself and actually having to birth
something into the world which is much
scarier clearly having Scott Rudin
behind it he's pretty much like the
LeBron of movie producers yes like he's
the guy so there was something on the
page that resonated yeah yeah I think
yes yes god I think it just seemed Scott
would you use the
authoritative night which I think or
which I think was nice or he just felt
like it was confidently itself or
something I don't know I mean you know I
don't know but but I think that's I
think it was just a nice little
self-contained thing that sort of was
going for some I I mean I I'm being
forced to describe how my own script is
cool I have no idea no I'm just really
talented and good and a product exactly
to sum up my talent man exactly I need
20 minutes to be able to even scratch
the surface of my ability well you guys
been doing interviews all day so I
appreciate you doing this but a lot of
what my podcast is about is just
learning a lot of my listeners are
really into learning and the behind the
scenes and I'm very detail-oriented as
well and not only if it's my podcast and
my stand-up on my writing I'm detailer
into it as well so it's cool to see
other people that are detail-oriented
and we all have a different process but
we're all trying to get to the same
destination which is the make a quality
piece of work yeah so even if even in
getting more on the informative side the
audition process I know you had to
audition a couple times and a lot of my
listeners are comedians or actors as
well so I would love insight into the
audition process maybe from the actor
side and how you approach it and how
what you've learned from auditioning and
maybe from the director side and what
you're looking for in auditions
um do you just mean like in general or
with this specifically yeah with with
your personal experience as an actor in
the world I know you did like Despicable
Me yeah yeah okay well on that side but
you could relay it to a Bose audition
process if you'd like yeah I mean um in
general you know I just kept going for
it I guess cuz like especially now that
I'm a teenager it's a little harder for
me to get stuff because I'm not what a
lot of people are looking for and even
if I am they could cast some
eighteen-year-old who can play me you
know in their eyes for longer and maybe
better I mean your high school or your
theater teacher will say oh yeah no I'm
it's just about you know keep going out
there and
it gets depressing a little bit if
you're not getting stuff but whatever it
was really nice when I came to the
audition for this though because I
remember like I dropped my script like
immediately and like beau was just chill
with it whereas I wouldn't do an
audition for some show after that and on
my headshot I didn't have my acne as
much you're like oh where's all the wow
it was really nice to audition for this
though cuz like there was a little bit
of freedom and like improv ish stuff and
it was just really genuinely fun and I
liked the project and that's like the
goal for anyone auditioning I mean I've
obviously aside from getting stuff is to
definitely find a connection with what
you're doing how do you how do you
prepare I don't know I mean just
memorize the lines and try to get a feel
for them and see what like it's all
about feeling for me it's hard for me to
think about it too much because if I
think about it I start getting anxious
and then yeah because even in this movie
like you would get the script like day
of right yeah what almost like Brody
yeah I only got to read the script once
full through early all the way through
and then I would get it deive for the
lines I think it really played into my
performance so it kept it fresh in my
head is are you a director who's like
verbatim this is this is it so that gave
the freedom to play ya know I mean
especially for this it's about trying to
capture the way kids articulate
themselves so there it has to sort of
exist on the sort of horizon of their
thoughts so they should be grasping for
the words and barely getting them but it
was pretty close I mean it was across
the board much less it was that not
improvised yeah give a Red Bull I guess
we need to get these kids on ready yeah
get used to it I sit there for 90
minutes to listen to you yeah and as far
as actors was that the question what
they should look like an audition do an
audition well as asking her from the
actors side and then from the directors
side what your audition was like how
you're looking from a director side I
mean it one's got different things I
mean I'm just looking for natural
specificity so not put on specificity I
mean by that someone that is more
ticular person exactly naturally someone
that is just something particular hmm
disposition Lior expressively but not
put on I'm kind of just trying to know
them through the scene more than I'm
trying to get like do they have a great
take on this scene so they make a choice
and I'm gonna come right they just are
and I'm trying to actually if I feel
them making choices I don't like it
usually I'm just kind of just kind of
get to know them I wanted to tell people
like you should know the pressures off
because it's so personal like like the
pressures off because you're your
ability to get this role is actually
kind of out of your hands cuz you just
gotta be right for it you kind of feel
right you got to look kind of writer so
don't worry like just be yourself and
and you're either gonna be right for it
or not
but but also just to just to be alive
and and and and be specific and maybe
take a risk but I don't know acting is a
beautiful thing a beautiful raw strange
weird thing and it should I think it
should be taken seriously if you're
gonna do it you know if you want to do
it take it seriously as a craft come
prepared it makes a huge difference
makes a huge huge difference I mean
anyone that's like looking at like that
if that is a you're almost you're like
not getting it if you're looking at your
lives I like really like you should or
the or the people that do get it 90
percent of the time our off-book and it
isn't just because like oh you chose
your professional like you got to be
there like show me what you can like
you're not showing me how you act if
you're glancing at this thing like so I
would say that but that's just for me I
mean that's if you want to be in a small
indie movie and makes admin um um right
now it's a small indie movie but uh but
yeah I would just say yeah do it you let
me do it like because I'm saying I'm as
a comedian doing it but like and I would
know comedians because I got this
audition and they like don't want to
take it seriously cuz it's like not cool
right admit to it
yeah across the board like try and come
in it's sometimes like feels like not
cool to try but like try definitely try
commit go for it
but memorize care about the audition and
don't get the part and be bummed about
it as beautiful but that's that's easy
and even just the preparation point is
something that's so overlooked now and
it can it can t fall back into just like
the story of the movie or even just
culture and how it's more of like a
microwave culture now yeah and
everything is just like McDonald's as
opposed to really letting stuff ferment
you and appreciate and let it learn like
your our specials
you'll spend three years developing one
as you know it became the system where
you got to do an hour a year our year
it's like alright we'll see how that
turns out yes some people the Beatles
that can do that maybe you know Bill
burr is that now or something I don't
even know if he's even doing that but
and most people are you know if you have
that if you if you're if your output is
screaming for that much great you know
but it's hilarious like the two people
things are woody and Louie it was like
we should look into people with high
output you have high output I don't know
I don't I don't think I do
you know my Twitter feed doesn't
everyone's tweeting me are you dead so
but yeah I think I think you're right
about it just more just like it's very
cool to just like not not go for it and
not
care and you should care it's just so
funny like out in LA when everyone's
like I don't give a [ __ ] I've been going
on the auditions oh who cares and like
you moved to Los Angeles yeah like cats
out of the bag you care you're a dreamer
I'm sorry like you're from Nebraska why
are you here like yeah so like not care
and a better climate exactly exactly
exactly so and like just circle back to
the auditions like the casting directors
the they notice when people care you've
noticed and you want that person like
you'll think about that person again
mm-hmm like hard work is super rare and
getting rare you know and I don't and I
and I need to work harder I don't work
hard enough and and so if you can do
that and develop a good work it like you
know it's really valuable and will be
seen as valuable and a competitive
advantage I would say just having the
discipline yeah is that we're talking
about from like the grown-up world but
even in your world more is that is that
almost the attitude of people your age
now too is almost the higher sense of
entitlement and oh yeah in class like
guardians oh for sure for surely and I I
I don't know if I live in a rich area
but it's obviously well off I guess it's
it's a nice area it's not no one there
knows manners and sorry the other lesser
problem I came from a mountain town okay
I grew up in the literal mountain so
where do you know Palm Springs in
Florida nope that's okay it's it's in
California it's a tourist town it's
really cool um they plucked you there to
put you on some range it's around about
300 miles north of Palm Springs that's
for shoes yes anyways so now I mean I
live in a well off area now and it's
just every kid there is just it's it's
so annoying how much people just don't
understand that you I'm getting mad but
like everyone is so entitled it's so
rare to find the good view
I mean Marines yes yeah but yeah I mean
I I don't know I don't know I don't know
if it applies to the acting world I
don't have a lot of acting friends at
least of my age I mean I good good yeah
keep you normal I suppose but I mean I
can be normal and harrell is yeah
whatever anyways I'm just I don't I
don't know if you could be normal of
acting friends maybe maybe like friends
that like to act but I'm saying like
child actors that are all like in movies
like that's a weird group I mean it's a
weird group but that RL is anyone normal
yeah you go Burnham is telling you
what's normal okay yeah I don't know but
then again I don't have much of a view
on it I suppose I'll um but especially
with kids my age it's like it's I don't
know if it's everywhere I think it is
though it's it's like mind-blowing how
these people just have no I'm I'm just
this is something I think about so much
because people just make me men cuz they
don't care about anything like
especially the boys at my school they do
nothing for work like they have no
career of head of except for McDonald
you know you go if that's your dream but
like takes like maybe an hour to do your
homework just do it buddy
just do it well read some Jordan Peters
and boys get out there you're not all
gonna be you know famous players on
YouTube you know I'm all gonna be the
next LeBron James yeah
that's what's so funny and even so time
about this movie is being famous is a
career path now that's almost like you
ask me what they want to be oh it's not
like a doctor it was me to start the
exam percent like seven years ago and it
was what do you want to be when you grow
up and most kids answered famous oh the
one I don't like as kids are answering
YouTube like that in my opinion that's
almost worse than famous because
no offense to any youtubers I appreciate
the website but like to like you have to
mm-hmm
like YouTube is a career and it gives
back to the community in some ways but
that shouldn't be something you're
aiming for like you should aim for
something with substance cuz YouTube has
become such a yeah YouTube is it's a
business now and it's not fun to do and
no one's creating anything over there or
saying like filming their own lives
walking around yeah like today we filled
a kiddie pool with jello and I'm with a
mohawk and like the fact that people
aspire to do that for their entire life
is so I filled my dad's closet with Milk
Duds
why and another thing is like kids want
to do that as a career but after a
certain point you have to stop you can't
just do that forever there's some people
to do there's some cool educational
stuff for sure but I mean like the type
of youtuber everyone's trained to do try
to be his crazy you can't do that
forever you have to make it like yeah
Airbnb a mansion and like scream at
people yeah on the street but even that
stuff requires a work ethic people don't
understand until they get into they
don't even want to hell well they're
hard-working gee I mean Jay Paul's
working is by busy there's just full
time job but like people you sparked all
this bow I don't know it's evolved like
what is he I mean he like did the
suicide for his thing then he comes back
the next day with the whole thing on so
it's it's beyond but even now you look
at like they're like oh the viral videos
and then it's by NBC or but oh yes it's
vicious yeah no no it's literally the
viral videos the day our trailers and
Tonight Show clips and and it's it's
hell it's it's a lot like a little kid
in his bedroom making funny songs that I
was never would have worked now now
doing it and you you stumble across them
and you're like oh that person is great
but they all vlog and they make music
videos and they're musicians and they
have their merch and it dirt it's I
don't get how logs are so popular I
can't sit through them yeah like I
follow people and it's like I've come
here for your content
and you're like watch me make a peanut
butter sandwich yes watch me walk my
four dogs I know you sound like old
married couple right yes crazy no I feel
that way well I just feel like come on I
mean there are good people there's like
the I'm saying there's like there's a
lot there's some youtubers on there that
I'll talk about like boogie blogs and I
like him a lot and his stuff is personal
and feels insightful and there are other
people people who are really using the
medium we know who we're talking about
it's those like a sane yeah people that
are crazy but like all like live in the
same place and they go over and they're
like 19 and they throw like cream pies
in each other's face like what and
they're all like vaguely hooking up with
each other and then it's okay you can
fix your hair like what is it how do you
know these people I am sad I do what I
was crazy I just know how how sad they
will be when they're judged by the Lord
[Laughter]
how are you guys even in the movie in
the movie promotion side you said some
of the top videos or trailers or whatnot
and we are more connected than ever and
it's cool you're actually to two things
that I can tell just from what you said
today that this is not just a flash in
the pan as far as your just your vision
and overall career is one you said you
shot it as if you shot the movie as if
it were gonna be VR which is that's the
future that's where it's headed it's
something people can't wrap their mind
around right now but that's going to
become the norm
it's just that experience and
entertainment yeah and you're you're
tapping into podcasting you're using
podcasting as a way to promote this film
which is on a boom right now podcasting
is on a boom
now so in promoting this movie how how
are you kind of staying out of the noise
in that sense and getting lost in the
current in what sense well we're talking
about YouTube and how it's a bunch of
its bunch of just like curated like
content that people are paying to have
in front of you how are you getting the
word of this movie out that may be a
little more unorthodox whoa whoa whoa
why duh people are watching people get
not you know I mean I'm saying I'm you
know I'll just talk about it honestly
and if people want to see it great if
people don't you know that's alright we
had fun you know and we'll try to do
some creative stuff but I don't know you
know I mean it's like that that kind of
thinking is the thinking that hopefully
the movies almost slightly an antidote
to or something you mean not just to
only think about I don't know like at a
certain point the internet all the
internet is a bunch of people trying to
figure out how to be fresh on the
internet and I'm just going yes with my
youtube money it's very easy to be like
yeah have YouTube money you were an
early adopters like Facebook yeah yeah
exactly yeah I'm rolling invite YouTube
money I just I died I don't know I mean
um this could very well be noise we're
saying right now I'm saying I'm just
trying to I think people can sniff out
when you're trying to I don't know twist
something original so that that your
promotion goes down as something other
than promotion and where we're going
just promote you want to see this
thing's the selling will be to see or
not you know it either does or it
doesn't and that can almost be a breath
of fresh air in us discussing people are
creating content not for the sake of
content but for the sake of satisfying
someone other than themselves like what
will this what will these people like
yeah yeah as opposed to being like what
will I like and then in turn that will
gravitate in just an organic following
hopefully yeah hopefully I mean that's
that's exactly how I've done things or
tried to just go with like I this is
something I think would be cool and then
hopefully there are people like me that
share
yeah well people shouldn't create
content for audiences I guess I mean
they can but like create stuff that
makes you happy cuz like what's the
point of doing stuff if it doesn't make
you happy you know well for you know
gold what for gold for blood but don't
those things like golden one Jar Jar
happy life yeah good
wow you guys is like one in the same we
really are it's creepy but we're
basically the twins from the shining
yeah whoa I just like you know though
that's amazing she knows she knows it
from ready player one that's fish oh
yeah I didn't I like I like the hotel
part yeah yeah that was crazy
do you know who John Hughes's do you
know John Huston Holmes I I've heard the
name um I'm not that cool though you're
very cool no it wouldn't make sense I
think I think yeah I don't know why it
was yeah I know and it's weird cuz a lot
of the movies aimed at kids now are just
sort of reused and I think John Hughes
was talking about something very
relevant to kids in the 80s and of
course it's a timeless quality to it but
like I just don't think it's that the I
don't think the pain of kids now is
grounded in the same place that it was
back then which it was back then it
seems to have been grounded in how do
you fit into the hierarchy of high
school and how do you deal with right
your parents and now I think it's much
more how do you it much more internal or
something maybe because we're like
pretty much living on the internet so
you're we're almost our own publicist in
a way where every day we're having to
update our lives to entertain people or
inform people like are you with school
are you are you do status updates like
big test today like okay I'm not on I'm
not a kid Facebook I don't know a kid
you're the only ones I use our Instagram
and Twitter
mostly because I feel like I'm supposed
to yeah
it was in a line in the movie nobody I'm
not on Facebook escaped and it was just
I showed up in there all the kids
believe me I use Facebook to change all
of the messages to Instagram I keep up
with the times Burnham I try to only use
like my Twitter for tweeting stuff I
think is funny and my Instagram for pics
and my plants and my dogs I don't I
don't I don't understand how people feel
then I mean I get I get it but like the
fact that people feel the need to be
like taking your breath taking another
breath like that I don't whatever I get
it
yeah yes but it's also inspiring to hear
somebody your age feeling this way cuz
me just looking from afar I'm like oh
they're all just in this and so absorb
but there is there's wisdom in there oh
for sure
oh and I think a lot of them feel more
like she does then I think you even
realize - I'll see you know I mean I
think I think a weird part of the
Internet is that especially being young
on it you feel like you're the only one
that thinks this is BS oh yeah I mean
but like a lot of the other you know
mean like I think everyone is going like
in a weird way that literally directly
relates to the movie cuz it's about
feeling something you think no one else
is yeah exactly
it's like I've been I've been a lot of
those kids posting annoying stuff also
are you like I can't believe I have to
do this
and yeah I mean I think everyone's like
there's very few people that are but
maybe they are maybe maybe I mean you
see a lot of exciting every day and it's
like they're not sad about posting a
selfie every 20 seconds they're like you
can tell what I stuck my tongue out yeah
yeah but nobody thirty takes of those
photos selfies it's a lot of space the
funniest thing is to watch someone take
a picture like right on the Instagram
story picture and then they don't like
it they have to redo it
they can't just keep taking that's funny
like with the Instagram story you take a
picture and that's you can't just keep
taking like if you take it right ready
to post she have to start over again
yeah so it's funny watching you yes
that over and over do you find in
creativity that it's almost the more
personal the more universal it becomes
um probably not unfortunately yeah I
mean I'm saying I wish that was the
truth but like the most universal stuff
seems to be Star Wars and Deadpool
yeah yeah I'm saying I don't know those
are incredibly specific like the numbers
personally though yeah cuz you you go to
the beat of your own drum like your
comedy special just an example and as a
comedian watching you do that and it
being like oh my gosh it's Steve Martin
again like it's not even like I'm saying
replicating Steve Martin but like how
Steve Martin put forth almost the his
big thing was getting a laughter out of
absence and not telling the audience
when to laugh but letting them decide
yeah yeah your specials are doing the
same thing and that it's just it's not
like here's the structure that it
becomes predictable you've really
created almost your own genre oh that's
nice yeah yeah I don't know i i i i yeah
i think it it's probably what's more
personals more univer I don't know
what's universal but it's like I never
felt like I was speaking to the universe
you and I mean I felt like I was
speaking to people that kind of
immediately related to me personally so
but it was a long thing of just finding
out that oh I think well I think that is
would be there is nothing specific that
is not relatable to people at other
people like there's not there's no
situation that can't be understood by
someone else because I thought literally
at the time when I felt like I was the
only one in the country like being a 24
year old touring comic whatever and I
found everyone understand what I was
going through really truly III
I was so self-obsessed that I thought I
was the only one they could possibly
understand this but it's all again it's
all the same thing so basically no one
special
yeah really you're you're you feel fear
and sadness and happiness they're
they're all the same they all feel the
same it you know
doesn't matter what situation you're in
as long as there's an emotional
connection to whatever you're doing
that's what old people and that's the
only thing to connect to I think the
only the only thing that's actually ever
happening is like yeah I mean you're
nervous or you're scared or you're
excited and you could be excited because
you just won the World Series you can be
excited because you just cashed a coupon
you may give me any you know but like so
if you lead with the emotion or at least
people will latch on to that as much as
you know they won't go all I've worn a
red sweater you mean it's much more like
oh I've had that look on my face yes you
know perfect well I have to say thank
you both for taking the time out to
appreciate absolutely amazing the movie
Bravo seriously appreciate I was
connected from the opening shot so well
done a lot more good things to come and
before we get out of here is there
anything else either of you want the
world to know you know what that seems
good to me man
that that is actually our summation of
the internet and everything that's
something really truly like we don't
know I mean we can sit here and talk
about stuff but the movie is really
supposed to be like we want to make a
movie about the internet that was an
instructive that wasn't talking down to
people we think it's a really confusing
time to be alive and hopefully this
movie is just a reflection of that
confusion not a you know TED talk you
nailed it it's educational and
entertaining so kudos thank you guys so
much for doing this yeah
I breath